he had a long history of violent crime
infatuation with extremism and mental
instability we know that he sent
offensive letters to the families of
Australian soldiers killed in
Afghanistan and was found guilty of
offenses related to this we also know
that he posted graphic extremist
material online as the siege unfolded
yesterday he sought to cloak his actions
with the symbolism of the ISIL death
cult tragically there are people in our
community ready to engage in politically
motivated violence the immense in Martin
Place also show that we are ready to
deal with these people professionally
and with the full force of law I want to
thank the New South Wales Police and all
the other agencies involved for their
professionalism and courage yesterday
premier bird showed great steadfastness
and Sydneysiders can be proud of their
calm during what was a very difficult
and testing day Australians should be
reassured by the way our law enforcement
and security agencies are responded to
this brush with terrorism there is
nothing more Australian than dropping in
at the local cafe for a morning coffee
and it's tragic beyond words that people
going about their everyday business
should have been caught up in such a
horrific incident our hearts go out to
all of those caught up in this appalling
incident and their loved ones on behalf
of all Australians I extend my sympathy
to the families of the two hostages who
died overnight these events do
demonstrate that even a country as free
as open as generous
and as safe as ours is vulnerable to
acts of politically motivated violence
but they also remind us that Australia
and Australians are resilient and we are
ready to respond now I do intend to go
to Sydney early in the afternoon to be
further briefed by you South Wales
police and other security agencies I
also intend to say thank you as best I
can in person to New South Wales police
officers and others involved in the
supporting incident I'll do more media
then I'll take questions at that time
when we do have a better idea of exactly
what has happened
plainly there are lessons to be learned
and we will thoroughly examine this
incident to decide what lessons can be
learned but I do want now in the hours
immediately after the conclusion of the
siege to offer these words of comfort to
those caught up in it and reassurance to
the Australian people